[Música]
segundo y último bloque de economía del
día directo américa ya está listo
nuevamente en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge vamos a hablar del reino unido
donde la inflación alcanzó su punto más
alto desde hace 30 años así de raúl la
economía en directo bueno también habrá
que ver como el banco central de
inglaterra va a reaccionar a esta
inflación que es una de las más altas en
las últimas tres décadas en diciembre la
inflación haya aumento hasta el 5,4 por
ciento del 5,1 de noviembre esta es la
cifra más alta desde marzo del 92 según
la oficina nacional de estadísticas esto
deja un 90 por ciento de posibilidades
de que el banco de inglaterra suba su
tipo de interés principal al 0,5 por
ciento el 3 de febrero según algunos
analistas hace apenas un mes ese banco
raúl se convirtió en el primer gran
banco central del mundo en endurecer su
política desde el inicio de la pandemia
el aumento de los casos de la variante
de coronavirus o micro tuvo un impacto
insignificante en la inflación según la
oficina pero reino unido- aún no llega a
su punto más alto de inflación se espera
que aumente aún más en abril cuando las
facturas reguladas energía de los
hogares se incrementen alrededor del 50%
ya el banco de inglaterra prevé una
inflación para entonces de entre el 6 y
el 7 por ciento y ayer jorge
comentábamos el conflicto entre las
aerolíneas y las telefónicas por la
activación de las transmisiones en la
red 5 que cuál es la actualización sobre
este caso bueno raúl parece que esa
disputa no va a terminar en el corto
plazo heikkinen t y verizon acordaron el
martes aplazar temporalmente la
activación de algunas torres e
inalámbricas cerca de los aeropuertos
claves para evitar la cancelación de
vuelos en eeuu incluso el presidente yo
by them saludó este acuerdo diciendo que
evitaría interrupciones potenciales
devastadoras para los viajes ayer la
administración federal de aviación
actualizó su lista de aeropuertos que
podrían utilizar los aviones con equipos
radio altimétricos homologados para
incluir aeropuertos importantes pero
advirtieron que éstos seguirán
provocando algunas intervenciones en los
vuelos el problema a raúl radica en que
esta tecnología puede generar
interferencias y afectar las lecturas de
altura de los aviones que son claves en
el aterrizaje sobre todo cuando hay mal
tiempo
por ejemplo para aviones como el boeing
777 que está entre los modelos
principalmente afectados emiratos o
nippon airways japan airlines y
lufthansa dijeron que sus boeing serían
afectados pero las aerolíneas
estadounidenses han advertido que las
directivas podrían interrumpir inclusive
el 4 por ciento de los vuelos diarios y
en el contexto del foro económico
mundial que se realiza en la ciudad de
davos jorge 100 multimillonarios
pidieron pagar impuestos justos bueno la
iniciativa se autodenominó millonarios
patrióticos y afirman que actualmente no
se está obligando a los ultra ricos a
pagar su parte de la recuperación
económica entre los firmantes está la
heredera de disney abigail disney y el
capitalista de riesgo dejan ahora los
millonarios dicen raúl a los
participantes del foro económico que no
van a encontrar una respuesta en un foro
privado ya que ellos son parte del
problema el año pasado 130 países
acordaron garantizar que las grandes
empresas paguen un impuesto mínimo del
15 por ciento destinado de dificultad a
las dificultades para el evasión fiscal
pero los millonarios afirmaron que los
ricos aún deben mucho más desde la
pandemia la fortuna de las diez personas
más ricas del mundo incrementaron en 15
billones de dólares es decir en 15 mil
dólares por segundo según reveló esta
semana un estudio de oxfam escuchamos un
poco
tenemos investigaciones que muestran
como la desigualdad está contribuyendo a
la muerte de una persona cada cuatro
segundos a través de problemas evitables
y solucionables el hambre la falta de
acceso a la atención sanitaria y en un
momento como éste la falta de acceso a
las vacunas
raúl y vamos a seguir de cerca lo que
sucede en el foro económico mundial para
hoy está agendado el evento perspectivas
de américa latina donde participan jefes
de estados de colombia perú costa rica
ecuador y guatemala así como el
presidente del banco interamericano de
desarrollo así mejore se le pregunta
entonces por los indicadores de esta
hora así que iniciamos en asia donde las
acciones cayeron arrastradas por los
malos datos de wall street y en europa
las acciones se recuperaron por los
buenos resultados de las empresas de
lujo que contrarrestaron la presión de
los elevados rendimientos de los bonos
estadounidenses y alemanes y nos vamos
directo hasta parís ya está lista a
natalia es con la información de la
actualidad francesa no va más allá
[Música]